bonjour à tous et à toutes
l'invité de san roque a dit ce matin
fred lordinot membres du ppm conseiller
territorial d'ensemble une martinique
nouvelle et membre du collectif de
soutien à emmanuel macron frais lordinot
bonjourbonjour un livre i bonjour à tous
ceux qui nous écoutent ce matin emmanuel
macron se dit ni de droite ni de gauche
au corps de droite et de gauche est ce
que la droite et la gauche c'est même
chose que de leur dire vous avez une
main droite et une main gauche
vous savez que ce sont des repères
immuable comme le haut et le bas comme
le centre et mariama qu'on dit il est
temps de rassembler les français les
martiniquais et de gauche et de droite
et de gauche pour conduire un projet de
transformation sociale est connu il faut
faire un blu ppm républicain il faut
faire surtout un projet où chacun peut
retrouver ses valeurs et notamment une
valeur essentielle en martinique qui est
partagée si la valeur travail
emmanuel macron c'est le candidat du
travail c'est le candidat du pouvoir
d'achat ce qui fait que à partir de ce
socle de valeurs à partir de nouvelles
solidarités et de nouvelles protections
puisque l'époque fait qu'il y a plus
d'inégalités donc face à toutes ces
inégalités
il faut de nouvelles solidarités et de
nouvelles protections cela transcende le
jeu politique entre la gauche et la
droite
d'accord donc il faut que le ppm s'ouvre
à la doite il va commencer un candidat
c'est joli talent de tpm aussi parce que
vous êtes pp je me suis stupéfait c'est
un beau moulin en ouverture c'est un mot
que aimer c'est à lui-même et mais comme
le mot fraternité
on va dire que c'est un symbole ce
candidat le symbole de la jeunesse le
symbole de l'intelligence est aussi le
symbole de l'ouverture
il est temps de dépasser ce clivage
devenue stérile qui nous empêche le
progrès ce qui fait que la france ne
peut pas se mettre dans la compétition
mondiale pour faire face aujourd'hui aux
états unis à la chine parce que c'est ça
l'enjeu
la question c'est comment nous
martiniquais nous pouvons contribuer au
succès du projet porté par emmanuel mac
alors pourquoi certains
insiste martiniquais pense que macro est
l'homme du système langue est un
opportuniste et ne vois pas en lui une
nouveauté mais parce qu'ils n'ont
peut-être pas bien lu elles n'ont
peut-être pas bien lu le projet de magna
marron qui a été un ministre de françois
hollande et qui a laissé un certain
nombre de bonnes choses fait que les
salariés apprécient comme l'ouverture
des magasins le dimanche à paris puisque
les syndicats ont signé un accord avec
les employeurs et tout le monde est
content le magasin fait plus de chiffre
d'affaires et le salarié es payé le
dimanche davantage c'est ça le résultat
comment augmenter le salaire net
plutôt que de chercher des questions
philosophiques stérile il faut s'atteler
maintenant à répondre aux besoins
concrets et aux idéologies stérile
aujourd'hui l'idéologie de deux des
manuels mac on s'y croit c'est le
progressisme le progressisme a été
inventée baky par aimé césaire c'est
aussi paradoxal que cela puisse paraître
aujourd'hui nous avons l'opportunité de
porter aux sélections nationales
fraction de le sceau de la société la
vision d' emmanuel macron est une vision
moderne qui fait que face aux nouvelles
inégalités
il faut de nouvelles protections de
nouvelles solidarités
il faut être contraire lorsque emmanuel
mâcon 10 pour 4 français sur 5 je
supprime la taxe d'habitation
c'est très clair on va on va envahir
venir on va y revenir mais quand votre
parti soutient amont il n'est pas
progressiste
si le porte progressiste je les dis ici
même n'est pas le parti de la pensée
unique
encore moins une structure disciplinaire
ce qu'il veut et le parti progressiste a
dit très clairement la semaine dernière
que les membres pouvaient donner leur
parrainage à benoît hamon emmanuel
macron à madame marteau et à rama yade
et ya même des élus ppm au moins un qui
a donné son parrainage à rama yade donc
ça signifie que le débat est ouvert
de toute façon face à marine le pen au
second tour de l'élection présidentielle
il faudra se rassembler et celui qui
aujourd'hui est le plus à même de bas
madame le pen qui porte un programme
excessivement dangereux bull et
martiniquais est ce qu'on peut imaginer
la martinique sans les fonds européens
le fch excite c'est la faillite
immédiate des banques françaises je les
dis à quelques amis qui travaille dans
la banque en martinique cemoc monsieur
vivront pas un mois après la sortie de
la france dans l'euro est aussi dans
l'union européenne
la question c'est comment se rassembler
pour faire face à marine rappelle encore
quand même si j'en crois pourcentage
il y a le premier sondage sorti
aujourd'hui qui donne
emmanuel macron en tête au premier tour
alors vous avez été entendu samedi
dernier par la commission conciliation
parce que vous êtes vous ne soutenez pas
à benoît hamon soutien emmanuel macron
et cette commission de conciliation est
présidé par le maire de fort de france
didier laguerre vous craignez une
sanction
le ppm n'est pas le parti de la pensée
unique
encore moins une structure disciplinaire
nous avons eu un très bel échange de
trois heures dans le bureau de mon ami
le maire de fort de france que je salue
pour l'excellent travail qu'il mène dans
des conditions difficiles didier
laguerre un dialogue serein apaisé où
chacun a fait valoir ses arguments et je
leur ai dit que l'objectif c'est de se
retrouver au second tour pour faire
battre marine le pen parce que c'est ça
la vraie question
les questions de sanctions ne sont pas à
l'ordre du jour
hélas ce qu'on veut c'est arrivé à un
climat apaisé aux élections du samedi 22
avril
puisqu'on va voter le samedi en
martinique tout à fait emmanuel mâcon
propose donc vous le disiez
l'exonération de la taxe d'habitation
pour 80% de la population une mesure qui
risque de mettre en danger et les
mairies absolument parce qu'ils
connaissent de gros problèmes
budgétaires montre au contraire au
contraire sans entrer dans la technique
ce il ya des gens qui paient la taxe
d'habitation bon à partir du au mois ou
à l'exonération des jarrets ya des gens
qui bénéfice aux anciennes conditions
notamment des conditions de ressources
c'est une question d'âge bon il ya des
gens qui bénéficient mais l'état
compense à l'euro près
en tant qu il doit être versée par que
le contribuable ce que emmanuel macron
dit l'état va compenser l'ensemble des
sommes qui devraient être payés par les
contribuables ce qui fait que la commune
va se retrouver avec le même montant
d'imposition votés mais non l'état va
compenser vous êtes élu vous voyez bien
que l'état se désengage
avec l'arabe à la baisse des dotations
globales de fonctionnement et que ce
n'est pas ce n'est pas un secret l'état
français est quasiment en faillite
comment il va qu'on pensait alors qu'il
ne compense déjà pas les compétences qui
l'a transférée aux gars qu'il reprend
comme il a compensé sont deux choses
différentes à la librairie la question
du du paiement en temps réel les
subventions de l'état est un vrai
problème emmanuel mâcon prévoit
d'ailleurs un système qui va permettre
d'évaluer les actions de l'état
régulièrement ce qui n'existe pas
aujourd'hui alors qu il ya une chose
qu'il peut compenser de sela 7 cette
mesure a trouvé un pour cent de la
population deuxième chose je vais vous
l'expliquer il s'agit de rendre du
pouvoir d'achat aux martiniquais et aux
français la compensation elle se fera on
va pas rentrer dans le détail parce que
dans l'essonne macroéconomique vous
savez que les manuels mâcon lui prévoit
un programme d'économies budgétaires
mais il prévoit aussi 40 milliards
dureau de de deng d'investissement la
france ce qui devrait permettre de
booster l'économie
c'est tout à fait possible je peux
comprendre que certains maires les
maires de france les mères l'association
des meilleurs de france justement parle
alors je cite l'association des maires
de france parle d'une mesure
attentatoire aux libertés locales qui
remet en cause leur capacité d'assurer
les services publics essentiels attendu
par la population
ça c'est ça c'est le discours de
monsieur françois baroin qui est
président de l'association des maires et
qui est plutôt du côté de monsieur
fillon donc on comprend bien que cette
mesure il la partage pas cette partie
c'est une shakira et mais il ya beaucoup
de maires qui sont contents aussi parce
que c'est le pouvoir d'achat il faut
aller aujourd'hui vers l'amélioration du
pouvoir d'achat des personnes les plus
défavorisées mais aussi des classes
moyenne l'autre mesure qui va permettre
d'augmenter le pouvoir d'achat c'est
celle qui consiste à diminuer les
charges sur les bas salaires et pour
quelqu'un qui touchent la prime
d'activité un smicard
ces 100 euros de plus nets par mois sur
la question sur la question du
financement
emmanuel macron est très claire il vous
donne toutes les solutions de son
programme j'invite chacun à aller sur
internet
vous mettez en mars suit un moteur de
recherche et vous aurez devant vous une
page qui va vous donner tous les détails
techniques mais la mesure
elle est tout à fait faisable parce
qu'elle va aboutir à plus de pouvoir
d'achat pour les plus démunis d'accord
plus de pouvoir les chats mais
libéralisation certains parlent même du
b risation du travail
ça c'est des mots ça c'est des moments
là il faut il faut être
il faut agir le résultat c'est que c'est
beaucoup de mots il faut assez concret
qu'est ce qu'il dit en matière de
dialogue social il dit la loi va
continuer à encadrer le salaire minimum
la durée légale du travail l'égalité
professionnelle
magnol mâcon dit il y a eu ni les 35
heures hne
non non mais justement non justement
c'est l'un des rares qui dis aujourd'hui
on va conserver les 35 heures en plus on
va on va payer on va exonérer de charges
sociales les yeux supplémentaires ce que
hollande avait subi mais donc il dit
dans les entreprises c'est les règles
qui doivent s'appliquer au plus près la
loi sera le cadre global et on va
chercher des accords de branche
il ya environ 700 broche en france il
faut les ramener à 200 il faut les
diminuer et faire que dans l'entreprise
il y ait un dialogue direct entre le
chef d'entreprise et les salariés alors
7h28 ne reste à peine deux minutes on va
avancer
vous aurez des candidats aux
législatives en martinique on parle de
chantal maignan dans le centre
atlantique
il faut il faut il faut respecter le
calendrier d'abord c'est les
présidentielles et on constate que
plusieurs élus martiniquais que je veux
saluer ici le nahd ducos monsieur mans
c'est le mda dès qu'ils ont donné le
parrainage à emmanuel macron madame jany
d'ulysse la mer du monde
ge qui donne aussi son parrainage à
emmanuel macron la question des
législatives viendra dans un second
temps il faut aujourd'hui rassembler le
maximum de martiniquais pour faire
gagner emmanuel macron assez d'élections
mais pour pour gouverner il faut quand
même et jean-marc partie le rappelait
dans son édito qu'il faut quand même
une base électorale une base de député
j'avais cinq l'année 2017 sera pas
l'année électorale tous les dangers mais
l'année électorale de toutes les
espérances
les français de gauche et de droite vont
se rassembler et emmanuel macron aura la
majorité nécessaire qui lui permettra de
mettre en oeuvre son programme de
transformation économique et sociale de
la france mais il faudra discuter chaque
décision pied à pied parce que justement
il n'y a pas de socle idéologique le
socle idéologique c'est loeb passé
composé de personnes de droite de gauche
etc
il n'y a pas de socle idéologique chaque
disque je sais que proposition sera
discutée il y aura il y aura amène tous
les mini caméra comprend une unité des
progressistes de droite et de gauche
fait lordinot je vous remercie sorte que
des thèmes il est bon de donner à tous
merci
[Musique]